غالبيه العواصم الافريقيه التي ستبدا يوم
الاربعاء ولكن يوجد هنا في قصر الاليزي
الجهات الفاعله
في عملنا المشترك في القاره الافريقيه
واود ان اتحدث قبل بدء هذه الزياره في
باريس الى جانبكم
لاشير لما نحاول نقوم به منذ نحو خمس
سنوات ومحاوله ان اقول كيف يمكن ذلك مع من
الهدف الذي نسعى اليه هو وجود سياسه بسيطه
والعمل مع
مجمل مؤسسات الدوله وشركائها وكذلك وجود
سياسه
تشرك بشكل تام رواد الاعمال والمبتكرين
والرياضيين والفنانين والعلماء في هذه
السياسه التي لا تريد سياسه تربه الحكومات
وانما تريد ان تتعامل مع المجتمع المدني
في البلدان الافريقيه المختلفه
ويوجد هنا عدد من الفاعلين في سياستنا
الافريقيه
وجزء منهم سوف يرافقونني في هذه الزياره
ابتداء يوم الاربعاء او رفقوني في زيارات
سابقه منذ اقل من ست سنوات في النمبر من
عام 2017 في جامعه جوزيف
تحدثت عن توماس واعلنت انه لم يعد هناك
سياسه افريقيه لفرنسا هذه الكلمات لا تزال
صالحه اليوم
ولكن
ليست كافيه في ظل التحولات الجوهريه
في السنوات الاخيره ان الوقت الذي امضيناه
في اوقيته في افريقيا لا يمكن تعويضه
لانني زرت 21 بلدا وكذلك اجريت الكثير من
المحادثات مع شركائنا في باريس والعالم
ايضا
ليس لدي اي انطباعات لان الواقع الافريقي
الوحيد لا يوجد الا في بعض الاذهان
المبسطه
هناك مطلب وحيد وهو ان يكون الانسان
متواضع جدا حيال ما يحدث على الساحه
الافريقيه وضع غير مسبوق في التاريخ
التعامل معا
في ظل ازمات امنيه ومناخيه وسكانيه
مع الشباب الذي ياتي والذي يجب ان نقدم له
مستقبل في كل دوله من دول افريقيا
وتعزيز الدول والادارات والاستثمار كثيرا
في تعليم وصحه والعمل والتحول الطاقوي مع
مواجهات التغير المناخي والتداعياته وكذلك
مهاجمه الارهابيين وصدمت الاقتصاديه
والجيو السياسيه والاقتصاديه ليس هناك
منطقه في العالم واجهت هذه الاوضاع في
ظل جيلين كما هو حل افريقيا اليوم ولهذا
السبب وقبل ايام من هذه الجوله في القاره
الافريقيه
ان الامر لا يجب ان يقتصر على القاء كلمه
بشان افريقيا ومحاوله باكبر وضوح ممكن
التركيز على العمل الذي نقوم به وكذلك
تعزيز
هذا توجه الافريقي لدى فرنسا ولذلك الكثير
من رؤساء الشركات والعلماء والفنانين
والرياضيين هم الان حاضرون معنا علينا
جميعا
ان ننظر الى حجم التحديات التي تواجهنا
ليس من اجل تبني موقف كارثي
واحيانا لاحظت ذلك في زيارات التي قمت بها
الارض الافريقيه ليست فقط ارض بؤس وانما
ارض تفاؤل
وعمل تطوعي وهذه الطاقه يجب ان تكون مصدر
الهام بالنسبه لنا وتشجعنا على ان نكون
جيران افريقيا وكذلك ان نكون احد البلدان
التي لديها علاقات بشريه ووجوديه مع هذه
القاره لدينا مصير مشترك مع القاراتيه
الافريقيه
اذا اصطادنا اغتنام هذه الفرصه ستكون
لدينا الفرصه لان نتناغم مع القاره التي
ستكون من اسواق الاقتصاديه الاكثر نشاطا
في العالم
وستكون من اكبر مراكز النمو العالمي في
العقود المقبله ولكن لان شبابنا ايضا
يجتمع اليوم الى موسيقى كونغوليه ونيجيريه
ومن ساحل العاج
منتجه في قاره الافريقيه
ولان القوه الثقافيه والاقتصاديه والعلميه
في افريقيا سوف تتجسد اكثر فاكثر ان
النمونا الاقتصادي الاوروبي وكذلك وظائفنا
ستعتمد ايضا على افريقيا هذه ليست بالخبر
السار او
السيء وانما هذا واقع وهذا يتوقف عما نقوم
ذلك لذلك انا مقتنع بان الوقت قد حان
للقيام باختيار وتحديد علاقاتنا مع
البلدان الافريقيه
وعندما نتابع الاخبار وهذا ما فعله واطلع
على وصف هذه الاوقات التي نعيشها والتي هي
بين امرين
الكثير من الصعوبات التاريخيه ونحن في
مرحله انتقاليه ولم نتمكن بدء العمليه
الانتقاليه
الكثيرون يريدون منا ان نبدا في منافسه
منافسه اراها من جانبي غير مناسبه لهذا
الوقت هذا هو الفخ الذي يعني الرد على ذلك
باظهار القوه انظروا بعض البعض ياتون
بجيوشهم ومرتزقتهم هنا هناك
اي تعالوا يا فرنسا وان ادخلوا في هذا
المجال وتنافسوا معهم لا اعتقدوا ذلك
هذا هي قراءه للماضي ولا يمكن ان نقيس
الكثير بناء على العمليات العسكريه
علاقتنا الحصريه مع القاده الافارقه وان
اسواقا هي حصر لنا لاننا كنا هناك من قبل
او اننا نتنافس لنكون في مركز القوه
انا مقتنع بان هذا المسار لا يؤدي الى اي
مخرج
وهذا ربما خيار ولا الذي يحلبون بالماضي
والرغبنا في ان نقطع مع ذلك منذ عام 2017
دون ان يتاح لنا كل الوسائل لتغيير هذا
المسار هذا ميز دورنا في مالي في خلال عشر
سنوات من خلال تضحيات كبيره لجنودنا الى
جانب الجيش المالي وجيوش افريقي افريقي
حققوا النصر امام الارهابيين وحيه هنا
جنودنا اولئك الذين ضحوا بحياتهم او جرحوه
هناك
سيظل ذلك مصدر فخر كبير لنا ولحلفائنا
الذين انضموا الينا ولكن ذلك لم يكن دور
جنودنا ولم يكن دور فرنسا تقدم وحدها
اجوبه سياسيه تنوب عن الاجوبه العسكريه
ولكن والرغم من ارادتنا تحملنا مسؤوليه
ضخمه وهذا ما جعلنا اليوم مصدر رفض من قبل
نخبه سياسيه ماليه لم تنجح في اصلاح
الامور في بلاده وهذا قد يتكرر في بلدان
اخرى لذلك لن اترك ضحايا جنودنا يعاني من
نفس اللبس ولن اسمع ايضا تكرار هذا الوضع
من خلال ربما الابتعاد عن تحمل المسؤوليه
حتى تصبح فرنسا هي كبش الفداء المثالي
ولتجنب تكرار التاريخ يوجد مسبيل اخر
نتبعه
منذ ست سنوات سبيل اخر
يجعل افريقيا ليس ارضا لتنافس او
للاستفاده منها وانما
تجعلنا ننظر الى البلدان الافريقيه
ولنبني علاقه جديده متزنه ومتبادله
ومسؤوله
هذه هي الاجنده التي حددت في عام 2017
والتزمنا بالتزامات نظرنا الى تاريخنا وفي
الجزائر وفي الكاميرون مع لجنه فرنسيه
كاميونيه ستبدو اعمالها التزمنا بذلك من
خلال اصلاح الفرنك سيافي واستعاده ايضا او
اظهار بان هذه العمله هي عمله افريقيه
يمكن اذا ما رغبت دول استديو ان تؤدي الى
عمله
موحده يمكن ان تكون لها اسم اخر
ولقد دعمنا ازاء جائحه كوفيد التميز
العلمي الافريقي من خلال مركز الازمات
الافريقي ومعهد باستور في داكار ومعهد
البحوث البيولوجيه للبروفيسور الذي سازوره
بعد عده ايام وكذلك من خلال تطوير مراكز
لانتاج اللقاحات كما قمنا بذلك في جنوب
افريقيا او بلدان اخرى
او فين التزاماتنا في المجال الرياضي من
خلال بناء الشراكات لتدريب رياضيين في
القاره الافريقيه وكذلك اقامه بونا
رياضيه لالعاب كره القدم موجوده وغيرها من
الرياضات وفينا بالتزاماتنا وسرعنا بفضل
الكثيرين تغيير نظره فرنسا حيال القاره
الافريقيه بما في ذلك في مدارسنا ومناهجنا
سنواصل هذه